let's get more now on that breaking news
that the duke and duchess
of sussex harry and megan will not be
returning as working members of the
royal family sky's royal correspondent
rhiannon mills
joins me now there's no coming back then
rhiannon
no so we have just had this statement
literally in
the last five minutes or so it's not
entirely out of the blue because we know
that
when harry and megan announced that they
were stepping away from royal duties
just under 12 months ago now the queen
at the time said there would be
a 12-month review to see how this was
working both
for the duke and duchess of sussex but
also for members of the royal family so
we know that discussions have been going
on
um behind the scenes i will read this
statement to you now
in which it says the duke and duchess of
sussex have confirmed to her majesty the
queen that they will not
be returning as working members of the
royal family
it goes on to say that following
conversations with the duke
the queen has written confirming that in
stepping away from the work of the royal
family
it is not possible to continue with the
responsibilities
and duties that come with a life of
public service
the honorary military appointments and
the royal patronages held by the duke
and duchess will therefore be returned
to her majesty
before being redistributed among working
members of the royal family
it then goes on to say and i have to say
this i think is the most important
sentence of all
while all are saddened by their decision
the duke and duchess remain
much-loved members of the family now in
practical terms what exactly is this
going to mean
well we know that harry and megan last
year announced that they wanted to step
away from raw life
they wanted this financially independent
uh way of life
but what this decision now means is that
following those conversations between
the
the duke sausage duke of sussex sorry
and mems the royal family
it means that their military
commonwealth and charitable associations
are now going to revert back to the
queen so in terms of prince harry that
means his affiliation with
the royal marines ref huntington and the
royal navy small ships and diving
also his links to the queen's
commonwealth trust
the rugby football union the rugby
football league
and also megan's association with the
royal national theatre which she had
been given
by the queen who was previously their
patron and
also what is quite striking is also
they're not going to be able to
associate themselves with the
association
of commonwealth universities and i think
there was some discussion about whether
or not they'd be able to
keep their their links to some of those
commonwealth organizations but clearly
that has also
um had to go now we've also had a
statement
from a representative from the duke and
duchess
of sussex their spokesperson has said
as evidenced by their work over the past
year the duke and duchess of sussex
remain committed to their duty and
service to the uk
and around the world and have offered
their continued to sport
to the organizations they've represented
regardless of official role
they also say we can all live a life of
service
service is universal so
i think this shows today that that
divide between the sussexes
and the royal family in terms of how
they saw any potential future role any
possibility that
harry would be able to keep those
long-standing military affiliations
whether or not megan would be able to
continue to represent the royal family
when it came to the likes of the
commonwealth
that has gone that is over and
i think some of that has to do with what
has obviously been some very tense
discussions that have gone on
behind the scenes we also know this week
that the duke and duchess
have announced that they are going to do
that tell-all
interview with oprah i think it is
interesting that the palace today have
decided to put this statement out i
suspect they didn't want it to look
like they were maybe reacting after that
interview went out it's due to go out on
the 7th of march
and so yeah today it has been confirmed
by the palace that the duke and duchess
of sussex
are no longer going to be returning as
working members of the royal family
and as you've described there's been a
review process going on
over the past year but given that
announcement
about that interview with oprah winfrey
this is perhaps even less surprising
isn't it because to sit and publicly
take part in that interview did that
make
it incompatible to still be working
members of the royal family and
representing
the royal family on the world stage
look i think members of the royal family
they simply don't do interviews
like an interview with oprah this kind
of tell-all style that we're expecting
where they are going to talk about
setting up their new life in america
where megan is going to talk about what
it was
like stepping into the royal family
where megan is expected to talk about
how she's been dealing
with the public pressure and moving on
as
she's pregnant again and i think
when you looked at the fact that they
had decided to do this interview you
couldn't help but think
that maybe this was a reaction to the
fact that
the discussions behind the scenes had
not been going
in the way that they had wanted them to
we know that
in the last couple of weeks uh prince
harry of course
won a court case against the mail on
sunday with the mail on sunday
suggesting that he hadn't been
keeping in touch with the royal marines
in the way that he should have done and
after that there was certainly a lot of
his friends briefing that he really
wanted to try and keep hold of those
military titles
also of course 12 months ago we know
that the palace was saying one thing
they were saying look we're really
disappointed but this is how we see
things working
then harry and megan would come out and
say well no we're not happy with these
new arrangements
and certainly prince harry made it clear
at a dinner a center barley dinner one
of his charity dinners
and that he was not happy with how
things had played out between him and
other members of his family
and especially i think that that came
down to his military titles he is such a
proud man when it comes to
having served his country himself as a
proud army officer 10
10 years of service with the armed
forces and he really wanted to show that
he could
despite moving away to america could
continue
to represent his military family so this
will come
as an enormous blow especially to prince
harry
and i think you can't help but read into
some of these statements that
there is this ongoing rift um of course
i know that prince harry he didn't do
very much to kind of try to play that
down when he did an interview in africa
where he was asked about a rift with his
brother
and he openly admitted that sometimes
families don't get along and confirmed
really that he wasn't getting on
um with prince william but the the tone
of the statement from the duke and
duchess
of sussex it they they don't sound happy
and
that final sentence we can all live a
life of service service
is universal it does you do get the
impression that they do feel that
they have been pushed to one side um and
not been able to
to work in the ways that they wanted to
but also the final sentence
again of the statement from buckingham
palace
the royal family they still see them as
very much part of the family in that
final sentence where it says we're all
saddened by their decision the duke and
duchess remain much-loved
members of the family and i think today
on both sides there is going to be some
sadness about about
the fact that it has come to this and
that harry and megan have said that
there's basically no coming back
and the queen has agreed that and said
that
really they can no longer represent the
country and
represent the commonwealth in the ways
that they wanted to